في نقطه الكثير لا يعرفوها وهي ان القبه
الخضراء لم يتم اطلائها باللون الاخضر حتى
فتره السلطان العثماني محمود الثاني في
اوائل القرن التاسع عشر صحيح صحيح وهذا
هذه نقطه مهمه جدا لم تكن خضراء في
البدايه وانما كانت زرقاء لكن يعني هذا
التكامل في العناصر المعماريه بما في ذلك
الالوان هذا جزء من ما يشكل شخصيه عماره
المسجد النبوي الشريف وكذلك اللون الفضي
من القبه الاكبر في المسجد النبوي الشريف
بعد القبه الخضراء وهي قبه المحاريب
الثلاثه وهي القبه التي يعني كما سنرى من
الداخل انها جمعت اصلين مهمين جدا وهو
اتجاه القبله
ومركز القبه فكيف يتصرف المعماري في
احترام اتجاه القبله الذي هو الاتجاه
توقيفي من عهد النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
لا يجوز التنحي عنه يمنه ولا يسرا وكيف
استطاع ان يتعامل مع المحراب الذي ينحاز
عن هذه
القبله عن مصلى النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
في حدود يعني ذراع الى جهه اليسار يسار
الامام تعاملا معماريا راقيا جدا وكذلك من
هالمنظر في الثلاث مئذ نرى جميع المراحل
الموجوده في المسجد الحالي ان المرحله
المملوكيه المبكره المرحله المملوكيه
المتاخره مرحله السلطان عبد المجيد في
النصف الثاني من القرن التاسع عشر
والمئذنه اللي في اخر المنظر اليزن من
التوسعه السعوديه الاولى نعم هذه زاويه
يعني لمن اراد ان يختصر مراحل عماره
المسجد
وتاريخه الموجود حاليا هذه تختصر له فاذا
نزاويه الجنوبيه بالكامل هذه تاريخها من
المملوكي
الاول مملوكي البحري ثم المملوكي الثاني
ثم العثماني والسعودي اما الجهه الغربيه
والجنوبيه
التي امامنا فهذه كلها للتوسعات السعوديه
الاولى والثانيه يعني اكثر من 500 سنه من
التاريخ نعم
ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات